and what do tribes do they fight and we
don't need to be fighting
we're loving people we americans are
this is the greatest country ever
everybody wants to come to america
and those who are disrupting and burning
up our cities
they don't want to leave do they they're
not leaving
countries born out of oppression from
tyrants and dictators what do they do
when they're free they say where is that
u.s constitution right
because they want to emulate this
shining city
on the hill now you're not supposed to
be here
today you know why i don't know if you
watched the debate i had
the other night with my opponent
i was asked by the media are you gonna
go to the trump event david
i said of course i am and what did she
say she said i can't believe
there he's coming and there's people
gonna be in my
district she called it her district
it's not her district it's your district
it's our district it's the people's
district
and then to take it a step further
because that's what leftists do they
just put their foot in their mouth
she said she was going to do everything
she could
in her power to keep you from coming
here
she did not succeed
[Music]
but you see that's the contrast people
you know this
we like freedom we want to manage our
risk in a responsible manner
we want to move about freely
leftists and liberals they just want to
control us they want to control you
they don't trust you to do the right
thing not with your money not with your
rights
but these rights are special from god
and not government
don't ever forget it now if there's any
indication about who's gonna win this
race
all the signs that are out there they
say well that's the indication right
well first place we know is gonna be
trump pence right
third place is biden and harris
and second place is garage sale
our president
needs an ally in this third
congressional district seat again
we need to make sure that joni ernst
returns to the united states senate
we need to make sure that we win our
fourth district seat up in northwest
iowa with randy feenstra
the first district with ashley henson in
northeast iowa
marinette miller meeks all eyes are
going to be on iowa
as they should be on election night but
every day
because we do it right don't you love
being from flyover country
we know what's going on
our president deserves to be reelected
he doesn't need this job
he loves this country
the promises that he made and kept
he's got the left so upset and angry
they've
never seen anything like this their
power has been stripped away in
washington dc
and more power has been given to the
people giving you back your hard-earned
dollars that you labor for
rolling back rules and regulations that
stifled the economy
and hurt your constitutional rights at
times moving to embassy from
tel aviv to jerusalem and getting out of
the iran agreement
right hey right
[Applause]
rebuilding our military to protect our
sons and daughters who go off to fight
for our freedoms giving veterans more
choice in their health care and taking
our
care of our veterans protecting social
security and our medicare for that
promise
our second defense being protected
and this president has recognized that
god is the author of life
and god is the taker of life
[Music]
we live in extraordinary times
2020 what a year we thought it was just
going to be about
the monster hornet right
and it's not over and as long as
we have breath in us right and we have
strength
we will fight for these freedoms
together
as benjamin franklin said this is a
republic if you can keep it
i'm a keeper i know you are too let's do
this together
no sleep for the next days let's do this
let's get president trump re-elected
earrings
let's do this we need to make sure that
this great miracle from the good lord
keeps going and going and going not just
for ourselves
but for the next generation generations
there after that god bless you let's do
this god bless america
ladies and gentlemen please welcome your
former governor
and the former ambassador to china terry
[Applause]
[Music]
branstad
[Applause]
it's great to be home in iowa thank you
very much
donald trump appointed me to be the
ambassador to china
it was not an easy task but i'm very
proud to have the honor of serving
our country in one of the most difficult
places
on this earth and i'm proud to say
because president trump had the guts
to make iowa and america
a priority we have for the first time
got a phase one trade agreement that
gives us fairness and reciprocity
and has helped us set records in telling
corn soybeans pork beef
and chicken in china
[Music]
[Applause]
the president also convinced president
xi of china to make all of fentanyl
a controlled substance to save
thousands of lives in this country
[Applause]
i'm proud that we were able to stand up
to the chinese
for their unfair treatment of the
weakers and for what they did in hong
kong
we are insisting on fairness and
reciprocity
in this relationship and i'm proud to
have been a part of it
working with the president working with
lighthizer and mnuchin to get the
progress that we got
and i'm telling you we need to continue
to have strong leadership
so that america can continue to prosper
and i want you to know how tragic it was
that the chinese communists covered up
the terrible
the the terrible virus that started in
wuhan china
and they let it travel throughout the
world
president trump was the first leader in
the world to stop
people from china coming to the united
states
way before anybody else had the courage
to take that kind of action
he took the amusement criticism
from biden and from the democrats but he
did the right thing
he also worked extraordinarily hard to
make sure that we got
ppe and medical supplies during the
critical time
to the united states i'm proud to say we
had over 150 airplane loads
that came back to this country to help
three years and three months is the
longest i've ever served
outside the state of iowa and i'm proud
to be back
and i want to do everything i can to
help this great republican ticket
with donald trump leading it with joni
ernst
and the judiciary committee helping to
confirm
amy coney barrett to be the next
member of the supreme court what a
brilliant
intelligent woman that will be a great
jurist
and we've got both ernst and grassley on
that committee
doing their work that's why we've got to
work
extra hard here to help her in this
election
and you heard from david young our
congressional candidate
and i might say he is one of four
outstanding candidates we have in all
four of our congressional districts
we need to elect every one of them
and at the state level i just saw a
publication from the
council of state governments looks at
all 50 states and how they've handled
the challenges
of the covet virus and the state that
has done the best of all 50 according to
the council of state governments
is the state of iowa that is a tribute
to the leadership
of kim reynolds in a republican control
legislature
when kim reynolds and i were elected in
2010
we were faced with a 700 million dollar
projected deficit
today despite all the challenges
the state of iowa has faced the budget
is balanced
the cash reserve and economic emergency
accounts are full
and there's a 300 million dollar surplus
iowa's one of the best
managed states in the country because we
have a governor
that has the courage to listen to the
people and do
the right thing to keep iowa
strong and diversified
[Applause]
kim reynolds learned everything that i
taught her
and she's improved on it i'm very
proud to be here to support this
republican ticket and i'm going to do
everything i can from now to election
day
to help our republicans get elected i
have never lost an election
and i want to help see this great team
all go to victory come november 4th
thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen please welcome your
governor of the great state of iowa
jim reynolds
you're the fifth speaker you gotta break
[Music]
traits
[Music]
[Applause]
they throw a lot better this way
more
[Applause]
you're gonna have a hard time believing
i spent my whole uh high school years
playing sports that was some really bad
tosses so sorry about that
we'll try to get them all the way back
there next time
listen this is an amazing amazing crowd
thank you all for being here today to
cheer on our great president of the
united states donald j
trump
the momentum the enthusiasm the energy
is on our side don't believe the polls
don't believe what the media is telling
you
up and down the teeth ticket people are
fired up for republican victories on
november 3rd
[Applause]
i am so honored and so proud
to be the governor of this great state
to stand with each and every one of you
to defend life liberty freedom
and a constitution that protects it
[Applause]
i am proud to be a governor
that puts her trust in our people
because they are responsible they are
resilient and they will do
the right thing
and that is why we
were able to keep over 80 percent of our
workforce working and businesses
open it is why we're getting
our kids safely and responsibly
back in school 75
of our school districts are teaching
children in the building
yay we can't do this
[Music]
it is why our fiscal health is strong
you heard former governor branstad it is
because of
republican leadership in the legislature
and republican-led governor
we are the decisions that we've made the
diversity of our con
our economy and keeping it open is why
we closed fiscal year 20 balanced budget
cash reserves full and a 305
million dollar surplus we're ready to
come out of this economy
stronger and better than ever
we got this
if 2020 has taught us anything
it is that leadership matters it matters
in your hometown
it matters in des moines and it matters
in washington d.c
and it is why it is critical
that we re-elect donald trump for four
more years
[Applause]
four more years four more years
four more years
he's a leader he's a fighter
he's a president that puts america
and americans first
and you know what fires me up about this
president and his administration
there are an administration of action
outcomes and accomplishments look at
what this
man in his administration has done in 47
years
unbelievable that government can move at
that pace
it energizes me it makes me want to do
more
whether it's reducing taxes regulations
uh watching the borders
uh protecting life 200 plus federal
judges two supreme court
uh justices and amy coney barrett we're
gonna get her there next
elections matter
i can tell you as a governor it makes a
difference
to have a partner in the white house
somebody that's working with you
to advance each of our states and this
country
and to move it forward and it is worth
fighting for
it is why we have to do everything we
can
to reelect a really good friend of mine
an outstanding leader and that's our
great
united states senator joni ernst
she has never forgot where she comes
from
she goes to all 99 counties she has made
her
life about service and sacrifice
she is a champion for our farmers
our veterans small businesses working
families
people that have suffered abuse she is a
tireless advocate
on behalf of iowans and our iowa values
and the amount of money outside money
that is coming
into this state to try to buy this seat
is unconscionable 120 million dollars
and growing
is coming into this state to try to buy
that
senate seat iowans can iowans be
bought can iowans be
bought and we're going to show them that
on november 3rd
let's get joni ernst reelected
you got to hear from david young an
incredible advocate i got to travel with
this man in his district
he went to every county every month he
when we were driving through the
district
he knew meetings that he'd had he knew
names he knew places that he would stop
had stopped unbelievable the
uh the just the passion and the energy
that he has
to serve the constituents that he
represents he didn't miss a vote
he knew who was his boss he showed up he
worked tirelessly on your behalf person
we have in here now she's not showing up
she's not representing you she's
fighting
david young to represent you and
congressional one
you've heard everybody we have three we
have four honestly strong conservative
candidates
running for the united states congress
and we have an opportunity to pick up
each and every one of them so keep doing
your part let's get it done
and we have with us a speaker and leader
whitfer and speaker grassley
i'm telling you what i couldn't ask for
a better team to work with the
communication
is awesome and we need to do everything
we can to make sure that we send these
two back
in leadership we need we have to keep
the majority
in the iowa state senate and the iowa
house because we're not done
we are just getting started and there's
a lot of good things to come and we
don't want to halt the progress that we
see taking place
[Applause]
okay so i think up and down the ballot
i think the choice is clear we've got
this one
this is one election we can't get wrong
elections matter and all you have to do
is turn on the tv and see the chaos
and the intimidation and the dysfunction
and the lawlessness that is taking place
across this country and i will tell you
most those states are ran by democratic
governors
it's unconscionable and it is
they're showing us what big government
socialist liberal agenda looks like
it's not safe it's not pretty and it's
not sustainable
they want to open the borders they want
to raise your taxes they want to pack
the court
they want to do away with electoral
college the list goes on and on and on
and they're laying it out there we know
what they want to do
well i want to tell you something this
administration
and this governor will never ever
abandon our law enforcement and will
never
defund our police they're keeping our
community
safe and a quality of life that we have
come to know
love and expect
[Music]
okay so
20 days is that right 20 days and
counting
you got your orders from everybody that
came before me we have to finish strong
we can do it this country as we know it
is on the line
so get out there fight fight hard
finish strong and let's all celebrate on
november 4th
the republican victories that we have up
and down the ticket god bless you
god bless this great state god bless the
united states of america
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
is
she told me her name is
[Music]
young girls
[Music]
me
[Music]
she says
[Music]
nice
she told my baby
every night in my dreams
i see you i feel you
[Music]
far across the distance and spaces
between
us you have come to
show
[Music]
wherever you are
i believe that's
the
[Music]
is
[Music]
my heart will go on
[Music]
one time and last
[Music]
love was when i loved you
one true time i know
[Music]
in my life
[Music]
i believe
[Music]
my heart will go
[Music]
there's nothing nothing
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
man
[Music]
[Music]
you are my
fire the one
desire belief
when i say
i wanted that away
but are we
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
i
[Music]
no matter the distance
[Music]
the one
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
tell me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that way
so
[Music]
ground control to major tomb
[Music]
ground control to major tongue
take your protein pills and put your
helmet on
[Music]
ground control to major talls
six commencing countdown engines on
[Music]
mission and make god's love
[Music]
this is ground control to major tom
you've really made the
[Music]
if you
this is made to come to ground control
i'm stepping through the door
and
[Music]
and the stars look very different
today
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
tell my wife i love her
[Music]
there's something wrong can you hear me
can you hear me
[Music]
is
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
there is
[Music]
god
[Music]
potato
[Music]
my words again
down in your volleys
[Music]
true
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
oh mother tell your children
[Music]
not to do what i've
been doing
spend your
misery in the house
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
boy
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
just a man and his will to survive
so many times it happens too
[Applause]
[Music]
don't lose your fast on the dreams of
the past
you must fight just to keep them alive
[Music]
the tiger
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
rising up straight to the
[Music]
what's the top now i'm not gonna stop
[Music]
[Music]
is
clear come
on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
outsiders
[Music]
i paid my dues
time after time
i've done my sentence
but committed no crime
and bad mistakes
i've made a few
[Music]
i've had my [ __ ]
[Music]
till the end
we are the champions we
are the champions of the world
[Music]
with it i thank you all
but it's been no better frozen
no pleasure crew
i consider it a challenge before you
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
on the way
my friends
[Music]
if you
and now the end is near
and so i face
the final curtain
my friend i'll say it clear
i'll state my case
of which i'm certain
i've lived a life that's
full i traveled each
and every highway
and more much more than this
i did it my
way regrets
i've had a few
but then again
too few to mention
i did what i
had to do
saw it through without
exemption i
planned each charted course
[Music]
each cap will step
along the byway
[Music]
and more much more than this
i did it my
way there were times
i'm sure you knew
when i fit off more than i could choose
but through
[Music]
i faced it all
[Music]
i've laughed and cried
i've had my fill
my share of losing
and now as tears
subside i find it
all so amusing
to think i did all that
and may i say
not in a shy way
[Music]
oh no oh no
not me i did it
my way
for what is a man
what has he got
if not himself
he has not to say
the things he truly feels
[Music]
i took
[Music]
yes it was
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't
[Music]
but you wanna be fair
[Music]
just feed
[Music]
feeling
[Music]
but you wanna be fair
[Music]
[Music]
feed it
[Music]
my
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
millionaires
[Music]
down
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
there is
[Music]
i
i would
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
always
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
tell your children
[Music]
not to do
[Music]
sun
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tape
[Music]
is
[Music]
i know
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she was more like a beauty
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
young girls
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
take my strong advice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
be careful what you do
[Music]
yes
i am a woman
[Music]
she's
[Music]
the chairs
[Music]
bye
[Music]
she
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cheese
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
can you feel it coming in
hold on hold on
[Music]
[Music]
i've seen your face before my friend
[Music]
[Music]
lies
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
but the pain is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
do
[Music]
so many times it happens too fast
you trade your passion for glory
don't lose your grip on the dreams of
the past
you must fight just to keep them alive
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
rising up straight to the top
there's the guts got the
now i'm not gonna stop
[Music]
is
[Music]
up
[Music]
tigers
[Applause]
[Music]
i
[Music]
me
[Music]
always in demand
[Music]
believe that he's a macho man
[Music]
man
[Music]
it's so
[Music]
[Music]
you can tell
[Music]
you can better believe that he's a macho
man
he likes to be the leader
all right
[Music]
[Music]
all right
macho baby
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my
[Music]
have your own lifestyle
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
oh
i'm so bad
[Music]
so
[Music]
you're always on the run now
[Music]
i think you're
[Music]
you really don't remember
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
i think they got the
[Music]
but you really don't remember
[Music]
how's it going go down
[Music]
when you're married for the money
[Music]
don't believe it's coming back soon
and you really don't remember
[Music]
is
[Music]
that they said
[Music]
is
[Music]
so
[Music]
some folks are bound
[Music]
it ain't me
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hear me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
her name is
[Music]
mother always
[Music]
the
[Music]
she says
[Music]
do a dance so take my
strong advice just remember to always
say twice
the people always told me be careful
what you do
don't go around breaking young girls
[Music]
oh
[Music]
a is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
cheese
[Music]
a
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
45th
president of the united states donald
j trump
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in every american heart each time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
thank you thank you very much
thank you everybody
[Music]
thank you very much everybody hello des
moines it's been a good time we've had
yeah i even brought a hat they said sir
it is so windy out there
i said well my hair is very powerful
it's very strong
it can handle it but i bought it just in
case it may get pretty bad but it's
pretty windy
so thank you all very much and i'm
thrilled to be back
in the american heartland with thousands
of loyal hard-working iowa patriots
and 20 days from now we're going to win
this state
we're going to win four more years in
the white house we're going to keep it
going
and i must tell you you know i've just
uh
looked the poll just came out we're up
six okay big deal
didn't we win by 11 or something we're
upset
and if i'm up six nobody has ever done
for iowa and the farm belt and the
farmers
and all no more estate taxes
no more anything i saved ethanol ethanol
is safe
for me to only be up six i'm a little
bit concerned i'll tell you that
because nobody's gonna do for iowa what
i did for iowa we've just learned
through explosive documents published by
a very fine newspaper the new york post
that joe biden has been blatantly lying
about his involvement in his son's
corrupt business dealing
and this is a big smoking gun the newly
uncovered emails revealed that a top
executive from the highly questionable
ukrainian company
it's an energy company which paid hunter
at least
fifty thousand dollars a month but it's
now looking like it could be
a hundred and eighty three thousand
dollars a month that's a lot of money
would anybody in this audience take it
i'll take it we'll take it
despite the fact that he had absolutely
no experience
do nothing about energy wrote to hunter
arranging for a meeting to meet with
vice president joe biden
i've been saying this for a long time
with that family the same ukrainian
energy executive
even sent hunter an email saying quote
we urgently need your advice
on how you could use your influence
in other words hunter was being paid for
access to his vice president father
who was specifically put in charge of
ukraine
and russia
[Music]
how about the russia hoax it turned out
that they were the ones that did the
russia
it was them no collusion
no collusion these emails show that
biden's repeated claim
that he has never spoken to hunter
about his business dealings were a
complete lie
it was a total lie he lied to you over
and over
because he's trying to cover up a
massive pay-for-play scandal
at the heart of his vice presidency and
everybody knows it everybody in
washington knows it we've known it for a
long time
the fact is there was never an
administration
more corrupt than the obama biden
administration there was never never
[Music]
[Applause]
just weeks ago joe stood before the
american people in a presidential debate
and told you that these claims had been
totally discredited
and that his son did nothing wrong but
now that turns out
to be a total lie now we can see clearly
that
biden is a corrupt politician who
shouldn't even be allowed
to run for the presidency
i was pressing joe biden to tell the
truth because the corrupt lame stream
media right back there all those cameras
right back there
they're corrupt and they refuse to write
the story
there wasn't one time in almost four
years
during my presidency during the greatest
political scandal in u.s history
a witch hunt a horrible horrible
disgusting witch-hunt that should never
ever happen
to another presidency again and people
should pay for the crimes they committed
which turned out to be a total illegal
hoax
that false and libelous stories every
day
false and libelous stories and they knew
they were false too
they knew they were false they were
never taken down by twitter or facebook
or the mainstream media never once yet
with biden today
they take negative posts down almost
before they even go up
they're trying to protect him they're
trying to protect biden
they take him down and i was just
getting off that magnificent plane
behind us air force one
and i had heard and i just don't know
this for a fact
but they say kaylee mcaney you know
kaylee right
kaylee mcinning good kaylee she's so
great
she's uh incredible they closed down her
account
she's the white house press secretary
because she's reporting the truth
they closed down her account so let's
see what's going to happen
and did you hear the news bruce ohr is
finally out of the department of justice
bruce ohr him and his wonderful wife
molly she wrote all this stuff and then
he goes and he works at department of
justice and he took it
didn't he bring it to the fbi the wife
writes it she gets paid a lot of money
bruce ohr is finally out of the
department of justice
that's good a couple of years too late
that's all
he should be not only in the department
of justice outbox he should be someplace
else okay
eight months after his alleged meeting
with
the burmese executives so this uh
buremicia bermucia they say pronounce it
barisia
a real beautiful company vice president
joe biden went to ukraine
and threatened to withhold 1 billion
dollars in aid
if they did not fire the prosecutor that
was investigating his son
and the company that his son worked for
that's
very mystery the documents
also show that before one of joe's trips
to ukraine
hunter emailed his business partner
saying his lucrative contract
should begin now think of that
should begin now right now it's got to
begin
it's the whole thing is so incredible
here's a guy look let's just put it in
simple language
he got thrown out of the military that's
unfortunate
he didn't have a job for a long time his
father becomes vice president
and he's making millions and millions
and millions of dollars a year
think of it no think of it
think of it it's like the hillary stuff
the crooked hillary
and it's the crooked joe
you know when a democrat voter here in
iowa
asked joe last year you remember his son
raked in money in exchange for providing
access
joe called that man a damn liar you're a
damn liar
kid's making millions of dollars he had
nothing
he didn't have a job thrown out of the
military sadly but thrown out of the
military
and he knew nothing about energy he knew
nothing about investments
knew nothing about china how about he
walked away a billion and a half dollars
to manage for china
they don't do that with the most
brilliant people on wall street
vice president biden you owe the people
of america an apology because it turns
out
you are a corrupt politician okay
joe biden must immediately release all
emails
meetings phone calls transcripts and
records related
to his involvement in his family's
business dealings
influence paddlings around the world
including
china and including russia including
russia
hunter raked in a fortune from china
while joe biden was giving china all of
our jobs they can't
you know where they came from iowa
and plenty of other places but they came
from iowa
he was giving them they were taking our
jobs they were taking our factories
they were taking everything they were
taking our wealth
and i gave you 28 billion dollars say
thank you very much president xi
you came right out of china and because
of that everybody's happy in
iowa i just hope you remember that on
november 3rd
hope you remember nobody else would have
done it
nobody else would have done it the biden
family treated
the vice presidency as a for-profit
corporation flying around the globe
collecting millions of dollars from
china and ukraine
and russia and other countries in fact
the wife of the mayor of moscow
gave hunter biden a check for 3.5
million dollars in cash
while his father gave away the store to
russia
including crimea remember crimea
the bidens got rich while america got
robbed
by contrast and this is so
true and so easily true and i'm so proud
of it
in so many ways i've given up billions
of dollars to serve as your president
and it's my greatest honor of a lifetime
it's so true
[Music]
i ran for president because i could not
sit back any longer and watch
the terrible injustices being done
to the american people and it's true
and by the way before the china play
came in
we had the greatest economy in the
history of the world and now it's going
right back there
our stock market is very close to a
number that was even higher
does everybody have your 401k ready
because
it's going through the room we're going
to have the best year we've ever had
and we're going to have tax cuts not tax
increases they want to increase your
taxes
[Applause]
they want to increase your taxes so they
can spend it on the green new deal
it's another beauty i cannot sit idly by
and watch career politicians like joe
biden
continue bleeding this country dry and
that's what it is
you know you can say whatever you want
you can say whatever you want
but when you have a kid that follows his
father and by the way take a look at his
brother
his brother all of a sudden is building
a big housing development in iraq
have you ever built a development before
no i haven't
take a look at the whole family it's a
corrupt family joe biden
personifies the selfless and corrupt
globalists who got rich and powerful at
your expense
take a look at the people that are
funding his campaign people assumed that
they'd be funding my campaign
i don't want them we don't want them we
never needed them
we don't want them but they betrayed
american workers disparage american
values
and crushed our middle class
for decades biden and his cronies
laughed while they shipped
millions of your jobs to their friends
in foreign countries in countries that
you've never even heard of
they live behind gated walls and they
flooded your communities with illegal
immigration
deadly drugs ms-13 savages
that assault rape and murder innocent
americans
they forced our fellow citizens to live
in crumbling inner cities
while they spent trillions of dollars on
never
ending foreign wars they just never
ended but you know we're bringing all
our soldiers back home you know that
we've been doing it for a long time
and it's not easy not easy the military
industrial complex not the easiest thing
but we're bringing them back home
we're almost finished in afghanistan
coming in
we're dealing we're down to a small
number
coming home by the end of the year
hopefully the end of the year shortly
thereafter
in syria we're out totally out and by
the way we crushed
before i did this we crushed 100
of the isis caliphate
100
we crushed 100 we have the greatest
military in the world and by the way we
have built
the greatest military in the world
so i just tell you from iowa you know
you're a very powerful state politically
you're uh a big state to me big in your
heart
but you have a tremendous influence and
a tremendous power
and you've never let me down you just
came in and
we won by so much you know they say if a
republican wins by one point i think i
won by
11 right 11.
that was early in the night remember
that
they said donald trump has won the state
of iowa then they said man he won by 11
points what's going on that was just the
beginning
then we won ohio we won ohio by eight
points they said what's going on you
know it's one thing you want to say but
when you win by a lot
and that was the beginning of something
and i'll tell you what we have more
enthusiasm now
than we ever did four years ago there
really is
[Applause]
and we have great poll numbers although
you know you see a lot of the fake poll
numbers they're doing they'll do
anything they can
they're called suppression polls
yeah there they go look look at the red
lights they start to go off as i start
to point
you know in one way they want the
ratings in another way they don't want
to have the ratings and you're telling
cnn that they're a fraud and they're
broadcasting
now that was one of the greatest
that was one of the greatest evenings
ever there were those that say was the
most exciting evening in the history of
television highest rated evening in the
history of television
and you know what the election we have
coming up on november 3rd
is actually more important it's actually
more important
in 2016 you voted to fire the failed and
decrepit political class and you elected
an outsider as your president
and i finally put america first it's
called make america great again
it's windy out here if you can wear the
hat i can wear
yeah should i take off the tie or not
what do you think
i don't know maybe yes
[Applause]
[Music]
oh it feels so much better
that feels better that feels good now we
can all just relax and have a good time
no but it's uh it's great to be with you
seriously we've had a great
history here together what we've done
for you
and what we've done for the farmers and
what we've done for everything
you know two weeks ago you had the
largest order of corn
in the history of our country right two
weeks ago
you had the largest order of soybeans in
the history of our country
and the largest order of beef but you
know why because
china wants to keep me happy that's why
it was from china because they know what
they've done to us should never have
been allowed they could have stopped it
they didn't stop it they should have
stopped it the only reason i'm your
president
is because the previous administration
did a poor job
so poor in fact that i said i'm going to
run for president
and you know what if they did a good job
i wouldn't have run
and if they did a good job i guess i
wouldn't have won
when you think i wouldn't have run and i
wouldn't have won
but they were so bad and it turns out
they were so totally corrupt
we did not come this far to overcome
this much and fight this hard
only to surrender our country back to
the depraved
washington swamp
you know when i would say drain the
swamp
i used to say it you know drained the
swamp and people liked it i hated the
expression
i hated it i hated it i just said this
is a hokey expression
and i put it in one speech the place
went crazy i said i'm starting to like
that expression
then i put it in another speech and it
went crazy i said you know i really like
it
i really like it but you know when when
i say drain the swamp i had no idea the
swamp was that dirty that disgusting and
that deep
it's thrilled if i don't sound like a
typical washington politician
it's because i'm not a politician thank
god
and i don't want to insult our great
politicians because you have some great
ones with us tonight
but if i don't always play by the rules
of washington and washington
establishment it's
because i was elected to fight for you
harder than ever and i'll tell you what
i
fight for you harder than any president
has
ever fought for anyone it's not easy
but i love it because we're making
tremendous progress
we're making tremendous progress and the
fact is that no
administration in their first three and
a half years
has ever done as much as this
administration has done you take a look
at that
and you know it's amazing because they
always challenge you they challenge you
and everything
they never even challenge me on that
statement i make that statement all the
time they just stand and they say
ah they grit that thing they say he's
right
but we might hate him but they say he's
right right now i'm fighting
to eradicate the virus rebuild the
economy and save our country from the
radical left
and that's exactly what we're doing
as a candidate joe biden has made yet
another corrupt bargain in exchange for
his party's nomination
he is handed control to the socialists
and marxists
and the lunatic left-wing fringe
that are really running that party he's
not running it let's face it
joey okay whether you like it or not we
can all be nice it's going to be my turn
someday
it's even going to be your turn someday
my friends
someday but you know when it is your
turn you can't be president
one thing i've learned president xi of
china he's 100
putin of russia 100 kim jong-un by the
way whatever happened to that war we
were supposed to be
kim jong-un of north korea 100 these
people are sharp
and this smart joe has lost it in his
best day he wasn't a smart man
everybody knows that but joe is gone
if he wins the radical left we'll be
running the country
they're addicted to power and god help
us
if they get it we'll never be the same
country and we will never be able to
recover
and we are on a basis and i'll tell you
something the country was coming
together
i was telling a very very actually a
very good reporter today
that our country was coming together
because we were having such success that
i was being called
by people that normally i wouldn't be
speaking to too much they don't want me
i don't want them
but we had the best employment numbers
in history african american hispanic
american numbers
women asian everything high school
diploma without high school diploma
colleges
phds we had the best numbers in every
category
160 million jobs we were never even
close to that
we were at 160 million jobs and it was
all coming together
people let's get together let's talk you
know it's like splitting up the riches
really and in a positive way splitting
up the riches and what happened is we
then got hit with the plague
and now it's back to the drawing boards
but we're gonna have a strong v
the quarter the third quarter is going
to be incredible when you see the
numbers
not that i know anything because i don't
want to give you inside information
because i don't have it
they'll say he's giving away inside
information they are sick
but where do you see the third quarter
numbers and it's going to be right
before it's going to be right before the
election before the november 3rd
although a lot of people
will have voted by that time get out and
vote you got to get out and vote
got to get out and vote but we were
really coming together because that's
you know look ultimately we want to come
together everybody come together
and we were really coming together and
then we got hit by this
horrible situation could have been
stopped china stopped it from going into
the rest of china
but they didn't stop it from coming out
and going to europe and the united
states and the rest of the world 188
countries
so we're now putting it together we had
it
done and now we're doing it again and
next year
will be even stronger than last year
last year was the best year we've ever
had
and this coming year will be even better
than last year
[Music]
unless somebody comes along and says
let's quadruple your taxes which is what
they want to do
they want to raise your taxes they want
to go with this ridiculous green do deal
which by the way their original price
100 trillion you couldn't do it for that
if we did great every year for a hundred
years
everything was perfect right no nothing
no recessions no anything
you couldn't make a hundred trillion
dollars these people are crazy and they
actually mean it
you know they actually so we're going to
uh get it going to a level that nobody
can ever turn course on us nobody can
ever change you know
i tell the story for years as a student
of
economies i just love it i love watching
it i love doing it
and i love seeing the results because
the results have been so incredible
but as a student i used to hear for
years for 10 years
2019 china because look let's face it
china's
1.4 billion people we're 325
not including illegal immigrants that
are in the country
frankly and we don't even know what that
number i said how many do we have we
have no idea sir well i have an idea by
the way
our southern border is now stronger than
it's ever
been
but we have 325 330 million people
but for years i heard that china will
overtake us as the world's largest
economy
in the year 2019 you've all heard it i
think right
yes he's a very smart looking guy you're
loaded with money i bet look that's why
he's in the front room
he's in the front row and he didn't have
to stand here for three days to get
there i can tell he's gone
but right 2019 that china was going to
overtake as well
you go back six months seven months not
only weren't they overtaking we were
beating them by leaps and bounds and
getting bigger and bigger and growing
and growing and
taxing them and taxing them and taking
in billions and billions of tariffs
and when they targeted iowa and the
farmers of this country and ranchers and
others
i said no no no you can't do that no no
you can't and i put a 25
tariff on everything and i gave a lot of
the money
although i don't want to say too loudly
28 billion i gave you
16 and 12. i said to sonny perdue
secretary of agriculture great guy loves
he knows more about farms
i said sonny what's the number he said
two years ago sir 12 billion they hit us
for
and last year 16 billion i said that's
okay
we're going to put a 25 tariff the
farmers are going to get 12 billion
and then they're going to get 16 billion
okay
and we're going to give that money to
our farmers
and that got our farmers even
[Music]
in fact i shouldn't tell you this
because they don't like this but
some of the farmers were making more
money the way value was doing it then by
working their asses off all right they
were very very happy
but no we took care of our farmers no
other president is going to do that no
other that's why
the that's why china got away with all
of this stuff for years
and we had plenty of money left over
after the 28 billion dollars
it went into the us treasury but they
got away with it
because they threatened a president like
obama we're going to target your farmers
we're going to target the middle of our
country
and obama would say oh betty we better
not get involved i said differently
i said if you do it if you do it then
what we're going to do
is we're going to tariff your goods and
we'll give a lot of that money to the
people that you're targeting
and you know the thing that most
impresses me about
iowa nebraska and a lot of other states
if you look by the way minnesota was so
great
all of them every one of them wisconsin
was incredible
they never came to me and said sir you
can't let this happen
they're stopping ordering they're not
ordering from us
they never said it you know what they
said the president
is right at some point we have to put up
a stand
and i didn't hear one even from fake cnn
they put
people on television that said i know
it's not good but the president
is right the president is right
you did the right thing because
otherwise it puts me in a bad
negotiating position you can't really
negotiate you know it's tough
it's tough i never i'll never forget
that about
the farmers it's incredible the other
thing i won't forget
you don't mind if i go off script this
stuff is enough with
enough with crazy hunter biden and
making millions of dollars a day
he made it because of his great
intellect
no but but you know the other thing
where's hunter is hunter here tonight
brother
hunter hunter congratulations on making
a lot of money last year
you know the other thing i remember in
the white house
we had 36 farmers come to see me i'll
never forget it and they were getting
hit really hard this was two and a half
years ago early
and they came in to see me almost all
farmers
and they said uh sir we're you know
we're hurting but
you're doing the right thing sir i never
forget this meeting
it's earlier pictures of it uh many from
iowa
but from other states but many from iowa
and i never saw because everyone's
always asking me for money i want money
here i want my
countries want money our so-called
allies are always asking for money
please defend us even though then they
rip us off on trade you know we defend
them and then they rip us off and trade
they're always asking for money
so the farmers are in and i said to them
you know what i'm going to do i'm going
to do a big
thing i'm going to get you a lot of
money and i'm going to do for tariffs
and i'm going to do this to
this very early on the strategy and i'm
going to subsidize you guys you're going
to be so happy
and i used a terrible word they said sir
may i speak yes you can what do you want
to say
we don't want subsidy soon all we want
is a level playing field we don't want
anything
all we want
right it's true i never heard that
most people they don't care call it
subsidy call it give me
cash just give me money the farmer said
we and by the way i could see there was
like a chill in the room i mentioned
that word i said did i say something
wrong
the farmers are unbelievable they're the
heart of this nation
they said we don't want subsidy i'll
never forget it sir we don't want
subsidy
we don't want that we just want a level
playing field sir
we'll beat anybody we want a level and
it's to this day
i tell that story all the time because i
don't hear that
most people they don't care you can call
it anything you want you call subsidy
you
call it anything you want i just
think you people are incredible okay
that's it
enough enough of that
enough of that enough of that we're
going to make him cry and he hasn't
cried in 40 years that guy
one of the most important issues for
iowa
is the whole thing that happened with
ethanol they were killing ethanol
and joe biden's vowed to abolish fossil
fuels he
supports all of the outside you know
this crusade to eliminate gas-powered
cars
and his running mate sponsors the insane
you know she's the most liberal
by the way did mike pence feed her
[Applause]
you know the expression in boxing or
as my friend dana would say ufc
if that were a fight they would have
stopped it right
mike pence we love mike pence and he
loves iowa too he loves iowa
he just left the biden harris platform
will
demolish iowa ethanol you know that
wiping out the entire industry and we
fought hard for it you know we went
through the whole thing where we had no
demand because of the pandemic
and we all fought hard to get keep it
going and keep the ethanol going and we
did the
12 months you know i did 12 months
remember it was eight months i said why
not 12
and they couldn't give me a very good
answer but i made it year round and 15
right up from the 10 15 and it's great
stuff and when the market comes back
which is coming back
but in the meantime you have inexpensive
gasoline that's not so bad right that's
not so bad
because nobody ever thought they'd see
gasoline with the two in the front of it
unless
and we've saved all of our energy jobs
and whether we like it or not
when we are having problem with energy i
called russia
and i call saudi arabia and they reduce
production by more than 10 million
barrels a day
and our entire energy was saved all over
the world frankly they're not doing it
for us
but they're doing it for let's say
everybody and we have an
incredible country and we saved our
energy industry our energy jobs
and we are energy independent and it's a
beautiful thing
[Applause]
[Music]
and by the way i also made a little
promise most of you won't understand
for those people in the ethanol world
you can use the pumps okay do you
understand that
you can use the pumps in other words you
don't have to go out and spend
hundreds of millions of dollars on new
pumps because you know with the
additional ethanol
the additional power some people say oh
make them buy new pumps
no i don't want you to buy new pumps you
don't have to so for those people that
understood what i just said
you know what i'm talking about right
using the pumps
that'll be okay to defend our rights and
our constitution
i nominated judge amy coney
barrett to the united states supreme
[Applause]
[Music]
court
[Applause]
right
and i'll tell you you know i don't mind
running against sleepy joe but i
wouldn't want to run against her right
now
she has to promise please promise me amy
you'll never run
now she's been great she's so
outsmarting these people these people
with bad intention
you look at some of the questions that
are being asked and you're just so
obvious these are not
great chess players let's face it
let's face it they're not great but then
they're horrible just horrible
nasty and she handles it like nothing
she's a great intellect and one of the
reasons she has a highly respected
professor who's been teaching for many
years said she was the single greatest
student that he's ever had
and that sold me you know i believe in
that kind of thing it's called
intelligence i believe in intelligence
but i just want to uh haven't spoken to
her in a few days i want to just say
that
we made the right choice right with amy
[Applause]
and speaking about making the right
choice you made the right choice a long
time ago with a man named senator chuck
grassley
[Applause]
and you made the right choice and you're
going to do it again i hope because
she's great
joni ernst
and they're right now in washington
fighting to
confirm our great new justice
our future justice of the united states
supreme court
uh joni has been fantastic and she's
been fighting for iowa
values for a long time she'll call me
sir can we do this you nobody called me
more on ethanol
than joni and chuck in fact they used to
duck their calls tell them i'm not in
just tell them i'm not
i can't take it anymore jony but that's
what a good senator is they want to
keep your state going they want to keep
our country going they love our country
they love our state that they represent
sir joni ernst you got to get her in
and chuck grassley we don't have to
worry about him he'll be around forever
he's great
[Applause]
you know what i love about chuck rest
he's got that voice that great voice
even when he's being nice he sounds like
the toughest guy right
and he's being nice and he looked at
comey remember you know the corrupt
fbi director and he looks at comey
he looks at comey corrupt guy and
he just said did you leak
and comey choked yes i did he said in
the house
now let's see what happens to him but
i'll never forget
chuck grassley and he didn't mean it to
be mean he just
sort of like got that rough voice did
you leak
uh uh uh what uh yes i gave it to my uh
college professor friend from columbia
yes
remember that ah we love chuck what a
piece of work he is
if democrats win they will pack the
supreme court with radical left judges
who would shred our second amendment and
believe me if they win
your second amendment is gone
okay they'll empower
violent mobs and shield deadly criminals
and terrorists very simple
joe biden refuses to even answer
questions unpacking the supreme court
how about this
they go up to him do you want to pack
the court i'm not going to answer that
question
you know why because they don't ask it
if he doesn't you know me it would be
like uh
forget it but they say you were going to
pack the court sir
uh i'm not going to answer that because
i don't want to say oh okay good
next question can you no can you believe
it this is the essence of our country we
can't allow this to happen
and the other thing is they don't ask
the second i put up a list of 45
great brilliant conservative in our case
justices that go by the constitution as
written
etc etc okay so
[Applause]
he's got to put up the name of justices
or judges whoever he'd pick
to become a justice of the supreme court
he's not doing that they're not asking
that question they don't ask
did you see the nbc thing last week
where they had an
nbc town hall it was designed for a
child
okay when i get in they ask me things
that nobody ever even
contemplated could be thought of this
guy they're asking them these questions
nobody can believe it in fact
nbc took a lot of heat they took a lot
of heat
biden's agenda would be a catastrophe
for
iowa seniors everybody knows that for
years biden tried to cut social security
and medicare do you remember that you do
know he wanted to cut
your social security and your medicare
now biden is pledging
mass amnesty and federal health care for
illegal aliens
decimating medicare or destroying your
social security
and the problem is we all have a heart i
say it all the time
i'd love to take care of everybody all
over the world the problem is our
country can't afford it
and if you start saying we're going to
get free education
we're going to give you medicare we're
going to give you health care we're
going to give you everything
our country will be flooded with
millions and millions of people that are
going to come from all over the world
they will decimate our country you can't
do it biden cares more about
illegal aliens than he does for your
senior citizens it's true
i remember when they asked a question at
the debate where the democrats were up
there you had all these democrats they
started off at 26.
and in fact i i said there's no way they
picked kamala
because she treated him worse than
anybody else and
her poll numbers were dropping like a
rock right but they asked
who is going to give money health care
to illegal aliens and they all raise
their hand do you remember joe he's
looking around
yeah he didn't understand the question
he did
you know at least he has an excuse
because he has no clue what the hell
they're asking
but do you remember his position he was
like this
their hands are all up we're going to
give all our money away forget about all
you people
that's a big crowd by the way look at
that
show it please turn those cameras please
that's a beautiful crowd
that's beautiful but remember joe so
he's standing there
are you always going to give health care
to illegal immigrants people that come
into the country illegally in other
words right
they come in illegally and under a plan
they have the manifesto they want to
give them a lawyer that's what we need
there's more lawyers now okay
they want to give them a lawyer they
want to give them education they want to
give them health care
but they asked the question and i said
wow
because i think they had like 26 people
originally but every one of them raised
their hand
including sleepy joe and what happened
is joe's like this everybody other hand
and joe you could see he's
you know for 47 years he's got the itch
because he's like
he knows this isn't gonna work he's
saying to himself because you know
there's still something left not much
but he's saying to himself this a
natural instinct right
a political instinct and the his
shoulder went up
and then his hand
so i don't know i don't think i'm even
going to hold it to him i'm not going to
hold him i get enough
how about the no fracking we will not
frack
do you understand me we will not then he
gets a nomination he goes to
pennsylvania
where they are reliant on energy and
fracking and the jobs
100 probably 900
to a million jobs right goes there the
day after he says he's not fracking
he says we will frack we will frack
and they don't hold it to if i ever did
that it would be the end
but never going to be the end for us
either is it huh you know that
never going to be here because we have
something going
that nobody has ever had going we have a
relationship with the people that
nobody's ever had
not because you know i do think i'm a
nice guy you know a lot of people they
say suburbia
the suburban i've saved the suburbs okay
i've saved the cerberus
then i heard i'm not doing well with
suburban women
okay
i got rid of no it's true they say that
but of course they said that last
election too
he will do terribly with women terribly
and then when i did great with women
they said man he did well with women
same thing is going to happen
you know what i find suburban
women period they want security
they don't want their home values going
down they don't want a low-income
housing project
built in the middle of suburbia next to
their house
and we have a rule that's a disaster
it's a regulation
and i said to ben carson and some people
i say i want to terminate they looked at
me they go well we can amend it
i said you don't understand i want to
terminate it you all know about it it's
a disaster
where they change the zoning and they
make it impossible and you end up with
low income housing all over the place
and remember this 29 to 30
of the people living in suburbia are
minorities
so this has nothing to do with
discrimination it has nothing to do with
anything
what it has to do is with the american
dream
the american dream we're not going to
destroy the american dream for
for stupid people like cory booker
and he was putting cory booker in charge
how about that one that's a beauty
yeah he did a great job as mayor of
newark new jersey that worked out how's
newark doing
this election is a choice between trump
recovery at a level that nobody's ever
seen before
and a biden depression if they get
elected they're going to double and
triple and quadruple your taxes
you will have a depression the likes of
which this country
has never seen before and that probably
includes 1929
okay and one thing we learned about the
farmers they don't do well in
depressions do we agree
they don't do well nobody does well in a
depression you will have problems like
you've never had before
joe biden would terminate our recovery
delay the vaccine prolong the pandemic
and by the way for those states
open up your states open them up
[Music]
[Applause]
watch on november 4th november 4th all
these
democrat governors that have lockdowns
right you know
i always said i said right at the
beginning i think it was me that
came out first you know they're trying
to say 20 years ago somebody said the
same thing
but i said the cure cannot be worse than
the problem itself
and if you look at what's happening with
these lockdowns to children get the
children back to school
like i'll give you an example the
children 99.9
uh baron trump you know he had
he had the corona 19
the china virus it's got 21 different
names i could go over it
but to me corona means italy china is
china and it came from china so he had
the china virus right
and he had it for such a short period of
time
i don't even think he knew he had it
because they're young
and their immune systems are strong and
they fight it off 99.9
and baron is beautiful
and he's free free
like my wife our first lady who loves
iowa by the way
our first lady she put out that
baron has tested positive
and i said wow and we talked about it i
said you put it out you're not you know
it's like
personal stuff but you we really haven't
i said yeah let's put
a aaron says it positive within like uh
two seconds it was
uh baron is just fine now he's tested
negative right
because it happens people have it and it
goes get the kids back to school we got
to get the kids back to school
get them back to school all right get
them back
get them back and when i had it you
might have read maybe most of you don't
know this but i had it too
[Laughter]
i didn't love it but you know um
you know it's it's a little tough and
you have a temperature and you don't
feel good and then the scarier part is
you know where is it going
it's fine you're at a 101 or 102
and then you say i don't love this you
haven't had a temperature in years
and then all of a sudden you have it but
you see what happens to people
and i went to the hospital and it's an
incredible hospital walter reed i've
seen what they've done because i've been
there many times for our great
warriors that come back so badly wounded
and
these doctors are incredible and one
thing when you're president
i'm laying in this bed not feeling my
best and i'm surrounded by
12 doctors one's ahead of johns hopkins
one's ahead of walter reed once ahead
these incredible
doctors and i looked at the alternatives
all things we developed in the last
seven months
and one of them is regeneron and i said
i'll take that one
because it very early in the testing but
it had great
numbers and i'm telling you they gave me
this and they call it a
uh therapeutic to me it's a cure because
i felt like superman the following
morning i felt
[Music]
in like i made a speech about a day
later two days later somebody said he
looks better now than he did two weeks
ago what the hell's going on
so this is what's happening we're really
we're making tremendous progress
the vaccines are coming out very soon a
lot of great
things are happening on that front but a
lot of great things are happening for
our country
i'm working to make the antibody
treatment that i received
to uh i want to give it to all of the
people that
qualify for it people in hospitals
people just before they go to hospitals
we'll clean out our hospitals
eli lilly makes a very similar drug
and we're going to do it free we're
going to do it it's not their fault
we're going to do it free so we're in
that process of
getting an emergency it's called
emergency use authorization
and we're going to uh regeneron and the
eli lilly
comparable drug we're going to give it
to everybody and i hope they have the
kind of luck that i have but
maybe i would have been perfect anyway i
like to say i didn't need it
i would have been perfect anyway because
i'm so strong you know i said that
i said sarcastically i said well i'm in
no danger
because i'm in perfect physical shape
and i'm very young
and cnn goes and reports president trump
lied to the american public
they said can you believe this this is
uh
this is i was telling last night we had
an incredible rally in pennsylvania
oh they're going to cnn i thought they
were doing it to me i said
we don't have too many of them anymore
do you ever notice you know at the
beginning when we saw they would always
have the
the phony people that stand up and you
know raise their voice they'd go home to
mom
and get bald out i don't know i
shouldn't be talking about this because
all of a sudden
but we don't have that anymore i learned
about the cameras because the camera's
never like shown look at that
look where that crowd goes to look where
that crowd goes to all the way back
to the buildings and i'm always telling
i never thought the cameras could move
and then i just noticed whenever we had
a troublemaker in the audience
they'd spin around they'd be in like a
pretzel right they could do anything
these guys
i thought they were like rigid you know
like a rigid piece of steel they don't
turn
but if we had in the back room behind
the pillar
somebody that camera would be turning
around like a snake 15 different angle
but that sounds good
that's a brand new f-35 fighter jet you
can't see it
they say it's the greatest plane in the
world and by the way speaking of that
our military when i came in the world's
most underrated general told me sir
we have no ammunition because we may
have had a conflict very early in
and i said no president should ever hear
that and we have rebuilt our military
2.5 trillion dollars all made in the usa
with equipment like that the likes of
which
no country has ever seen before we are
the envy of russia
and china and any other country we have
equipment
that nobody has our missiles our rockets
our nuclear has been totally upgraded
and pray to god we never
have to use it because i see what
happens pray to god
but if we didn't have that we could be
in very big trouble it's a very tough
situation but you look at the new tanks
that we've ordered from
ohio by the way we kept the
lima the lima plant i said keep it open
they were going to close it i said keep
it open
before i became president i said keep it
open because i visited
i said you could never build a plan like
this you could never get the people to
make the tanks and we're going to be
ordering tents
we've totally rebuilt our military
we have the greatest missiles rockets
tanks
fighters bombers tankers
ships in the world
all made in the usa
[Applause]
you can be proud of your country look at
this young handsome
this young handsome farmer you're going
to be a farmer someday you're going to
be a farmer
huh he goes hell yeah i'd like to be a
farmer too sometimes
we're joined tonight by some incredible
friends and great people
your governor who's done an incredible
job kim
reynolds and kevin her husband
thank you thank you thank you
really great job kim how we doing by the
way okay we're looking good
that's good thank you for everything ken
as well as lieutenant governor
adam greg adam thank you
thank you very much adam great job
iowa secretary of agriculture
mike nagy mike
where's mike thank you mike
iowa senate majority leader jack
whitford thank you
see the way they all stay together they
like each other
speaker of the iowa house oh you got to
tell me this
this is good genes i think right there
are genes involved here right
pat grassley right good genes
what's the relationship pat huh
that's good stuff you got good stock
i want to bet on that guy in the future
thank you very much great job i hear
you're doing a great job we're doing all
right
good thank you pat ambassador terry
branstad
okay i can i do we have time for one
quick story about branson
okay because his son eric is even better
than him but i'm not going to talk about
it
and here's a guy that doesn't mind me
saying you know a lot of fathers they
get angry if you say that oh i'm better
than my son
those are not great fathers this guy's
proud his son is great but
when i met terry was long before i
thought about this and i heard the
governor of iowa's in new york
and he wanted to see me i said uh what
the hell do i want to see the governor
of iowa for
you know i'm putting up buildings and
i'm saying all right
and i invited him before i ever thought
about really doing this you know early
on at least
and he came up and a humble guy
great guy handsome guy that face right
and he sat down i figured i'd give him
like five minutes
kim no longer than that five and i ended
up spending an hour and a half
i said that is the smartest governor and
then i learned
and as you know he was the governor for
24 years that's an all-time record in
the united states right
2024
and he told me a story in the first
meeting that was before i think that i
was even thinking about doing this
and again it's only because obama and
biden were so bad i said let me do it
i wish i didn't have to but i'm having a
lot of fun because we're making such
progress
but he told me a story he said you know
many years ago i met a man
in china because he was selling corn can
you believe it right
corn crops and he was selling corn
and he said to his wife this is 35 40
years ago he said
i met a man in china and it went home to
my wife
and i said you know i just met the next
president
of china many years forward but i just
met a future president of china
and i said who was that it was president
xi who's now the president of china
and i said you got to be kidding he said
nope i could tell right from the
beginning
he was different and he was i'm not
happy with what's going on just
but he said i just met the next
president and then i remembered that
story and then i ran and he was so
incredible to me in
iowa and he wanted us to win and his son
was
very much in charge of what we were
doing and it worked out great
we won by a lot and then we won the
whole thing and i said you know we have
to pick somebody really smart for china
and i said you know the governor of iowa
came to me and told me that story and i
called him i said how would you like to
be ambassador to china
and he said sir i've been doing this for
24 years it would be an honor
and i have to tell you this he
represented us
great with china
he represented it i never told that
story
i never told that story but about a
month ago he called he said sir i want
to come home now
i want to make sure you get reelected i
want to come home and
he's out there i know he's out there
working but we love him he's a special
guy
you've got a couple of real beauties
with grassley and with this guy i'll
tell you what a couple of great people
thank you very much for everything great
job you did is
the only question i have is do we call
you mr ambassador or mr governor
what do you like he said either one's
okay
that's him anyway thank you very much
great job
i want to introduce another one who's
one of the best maybe the best in the
whole country
he's the chairman of the iowa gop
jeff kaufman
you look good jeff you lost weight joe
you lost
weight i'm proud of you jeff you do a
great job how are we doing
he said i always ask always be careful
he said i
was yours i said never say that the last
one you know
veto remember when he said that he was
running for president he was doing okay
and he was on the cover of a third-rate
magazine called vanity fair
and he made the statement i was born to
do this i said that's the end of his
political career and i was
he was born to do it that didn't work
out uh i hear we're doing great thank
you very much
thank you very much i appreciate it
congressional candidate a star a guy
who's going to be fantastic
david young david thank you
you got a lot of good candidates we're
also joined by a very special guest one
of the greatest
wrestlers in american history you know
that right
he's an unbelievable guy i've known
about him for a long time
do we all love jim jordan our
congressman right right
jim jordan jim jordan is a great
wrestler a great uh
ncaa champion and a lot of people don't
know that but jim and jim's from ohio
but he says the greatest of them all is
a guy named
dan gable you ever hear of dan
[Applause]
and listen to this i mean i have to tell
you is dan here i hope he's here
come out there come on come on
look at this you mean i can't take this
guy in a fight can you believe wow
hey dan i'm immune and i can't give it
to you so that's good
we love you so but i met dad a few years
ago
and i looked at him and i said how come
he's 181 181-1 think of it
he won a hundred and eighty when people
don't know like
that's like crazy 181 and one i'm going
to ask you later on who is the one
i want to find out who but he did
something else he won the olympics
1972.
and to do that he had a wrestle against
the six
greatest wrestlers in that weight class
in the world
and he did something never did done
before he didn't yield one point
throughout the whole thing
[Music]
and he ended up beating in the
olympic finals for the gold medal he
beat the great
russian wrestler didn't get a point
he went through the whole thing nobody
got a point and i'm looking at him and
i'm saying to myself i'm telling you i
could take him but i better not try it
but dan has been inducted into the usa
wrestling hall of fame
the u.s olympic hall of fame the
national wrestling hall of fame
and the united world wrestling hall of
fame
and he's become university of iowa's
all-time most winning coach in fact jim
jordan said
he was as great a coach as he was a
wrestler he won many
how many championships did you win as a
coaster
15 and i come from a town where you have
the jets they never win
you have the mets they never were he won
15. that's
called talent it's called extraordinary
talent actually
and what i did is i thought about it i
thought about it long and hard we're
very selective
so the congressional medal of honor and
the presidential medal of freedom
are the two greatest awards you can get
in our country and i'm proud to announce
that i will be awarding very shortly at
the white house in the oval office coach
gable
the presidential medal of freedom
wow that's that's humbling
that's humbling because uh that's the
highest honor
i'm used to winning and have to doing it
on the mat
but because i did it so many times on
the mat
and in other places that i'm actually
getting some other awards where i can
just do it and they give it to me
see the thing about this guy
is i've coached
a lot of athletes over all the years
and i'll tell you what when i look at
them
and i hear them they kind of remind me
a little bit of this guy right here and
and every one of them you had to
mold every one of them you had to learn
a little bit more
they had to get better and
every one of them did and that's why
they were not just
one-time champions this guy's already
a one-time champion but
because he's open for learning
and he's already very competent
that he's going to be a multi champion
president of the united states of
america
well he's the pride of iowa and he's uh
he's great you know you always try and
figure out
what makes a champion because you look
at him nice guy
good looking guy all that stuff but why
is he
181-1 why is he a gold medalist that's
done something that nobody ever did
didn't allow one point of any of these
wrestlers and they're all the best in
the world the toughest
and there's just something different and
you'll probably never figure it out it
is with great champions you see it and
you see it all the time with great
champions
but there are very few jack nicklaus you
see it
tiger got the same award when tiger won
the masses a few months ago i said you
know what that's an incredible thing he
did
and we gave him the presidential medal
of freedom and he said it's one of the
greatest honors he actually said it's
his greatest honor
i said uh tiger you deserve it you know
he went through a lot
and he came back and but you have great
champions
and they're different and nobody knows
why
that man is different and he's a
champion and it's an
honor to present you to the people that
love you most iowa thank you thank you
under my administration we built the
greatest economy in the history of the
world
and now we're doing it again we've got a
v-shape we're going to see some
very big numbers and you're seeing it in
my first three years
family income increased by six thousand
dollars
that's more than five times the gains in
all eight years under the last
administration
african-american income grew nine times
more than it did under
biden and obama we lifted 6.6 million
americans
out of poverty so proud of that
african-american
unemployment hispanic american
unemployment
and asian-american unemployment all
reached
the lowest levels in history
at the end of the last administration
the congressional budget office
projected fewer than two million
jobs would be created over the next
three years
and we crushed that prediction and
created
almost eight million jobs nobody can
believe it
[Applause]
we're doing it again my policies have
benefited those who needed it the most
the bottom 50 percent of households saw
an astonishing
40 increase in net worth after our tax
cuts
wages grew fastest for the nicest
i mean it makes me feel so good blue
collar
workers they were the ones that had the
biggest benefit
from what we did since the china virus
we have created a record 11.4
million jobs that's a record we've never
created jobs
at a level at which we're creating them
now
we've already cut the unemployment rate
in half we're down to
7.8 percent sounds high but a lot of
people said we're going to be at 42
we're down to 7.8 and going down rapidly
under biden it took 30 months to recover
more than half of the jobs lost
30 months we did it in five months
jobs have been recovering
think of this jobs have been recovering
23 times faster than the obama
biden recovery 23 times faster
not 23 23 times faster
i've spent the last four years reversing
the damage
joe biden inflicted over the last 47
years
he supported nafta a disaster
now you have usmca it's the best it's
now kicked in
he supported tpp would have destroyed
your farms would have destroyed
everything and our auto industry would
have been gone
and he supported china's entry into the
world trade organization a catastrophe
for our nation
you know china tries to get away with
the fact that they are a developing
nation
not anymore if biden wins
china wins that's what's going to happen
if biden wins
china will own our country they'll own
it
and if we win iowa wins and america wins
that we're going to win for a long time
[Applause]
for decades our politicians spent
trillions of dollars rebuilding
foreign nations fighting foreign wars
and defending foreign borders but now we
are finally protecting
our nation rebuilding our cities and we
are bringing
our jobs our factories and our troops
back home to the usa where they belong
[Applause]
and as i mentioned one of the things
that was very important to me
was to eliminate the very unfair estate
tax or
death tax on small businesses and farms
so now if you love your child and you're
a farmer and you think he's doing a
great job or she's doing a great job
and she wants to keep the farm or he
wants to keep the farm
there is no more estate tax where they
have to go out and borrow a fortune
to pay the tax
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is there anybody here who has a child
to which they do not want to leave the
farm because they don't like their child
because raise your hand please does
anybody have the courage yeah there's
one person over there
he says he's only kid no but it's a big
thing i mean look it's a big thing a lot
of farms are put out of business the
parents
they pass away they leave the farm to
the son the daughter to the family and
the family has to go out and borrow a
fortune and then they have a little bad
season a couple of bad seasons
and they end up losing everything we
don't have that anymore we don't have we
cut the estate tax it's out gone
[Applause]
these are things a lot of people don't
even know we've got that along with the
tax cuts we got that
biden wants to repeal our tax cuts and
massively raise taxes on your family
farms
and what we did was hit the
uh you know this i mean you you know
exactly we hit it so quickly we hit
so hard we hit so strong on this whole
tax situation
because the farmers were being untreated
with being treated
unfairly so unfairly with respect
to taxes i quickly issued a major
disaster declaration
and i will be with you every step of the
way i think kim will say this your
governor
when you had floods all over the place
you were like a large-scale swimming
pool i hate to say in iowa i looked at
the pictures that
your governor sent i said kim i never
knew that this was ocean front property
and we took care of you right we gave
you everything you needed and we got rid
of all of the we've rebuilt the dams and
the dikes
right we rebuilt it and we rebuilt it
fast my opponent has put forward a
radical plan
to eliminate u.s borders by implementing
catch and release
opposing deadly sanctuary cities
and suspending all removals of illegal
aliens so if you have somebody that's
a murderer rapist we can't do it they
agreed with bernie sanders crazy burn
him
there's nobody that knows how to lose
like bernie four years ago he lost he
went home happy
he lost again because pocahontas refused
to get out of the race otherwise
i would have been running against bernie
i don't know which is better there would
have been a lot more enthusiasm for
burning smaller base
more enthusiasm but he got i'll tell you
we're going to get a lot of the bernie
voters because they don't like joe and
they love our policy on dealing with
other nations because they love our
policy on trade
because they they understand they have
to understand that but they also know we
can do something about it bernie would
have never
never been able to do that the united
states would be completely overrun in a
matter of days
under my leadership we achieve the most
secure border in u.s history
and we are finishing the wall it's now
over 400 miles long it's already built
and as i said mexico is paying for the
wall
[Music]
you know we did more one of these fake
reporters said it we did more
one of the only politicians that's ever
run forget about politician but one of
the only politicians ever run
that actually has done more than he or
she has promised
as an example i campaigned a lot in iowa
i never mentioned the word space force
but when i got into office i realized i
looked at russia
i looked at kim jong-un i looked at
china
i said we need a space force and we got
space force i never talked about it on
the campaign trail
we also passed va choice for our great
veterans and va
accountability things that they said
were impossible to get done
so now instead of waiting online for
weeks and weeks
if they have to wait they go out to a
doctor we pay the bill and it's been a
great thing 91
approval rating in the va they're doing
a great job over there
think of it i mean i shouldn't be
telling you this because they'll find a
vet someplace is unhappy
but think of it all our lives we used to
see on the evening news
horror shows with the vets and the vets
and the vets and it's terrible what
they're doing
you don't see any stories about the va
you don't see any stories
we have done 91 approval rating by the
vets for the va the job we're doing
and we defeated 100
you know we're bringing our soldiers
home but we defeated
100 of the isis caliphate
in syria and iraq and when i took over
it was a mess
and we killed the leader of isis
al-baghdadi they were looking for him
for years and years
and we then took out the world's number
one terrorists and the mass murder of
american troops and many other troops
and many other people kasim sullivani
is dead dead
one of the biggest things to happen in
the middle east in 50 years
i withdrew from the last
administration's disastrous
iran nuclear catastrophe
150 billion dollars 1.8 billion dollars
in cash
for nothing the deal is practically
expiring now anyway if we didn't
determinate it
i kept my promise recognized the true
capital of israel
and opened the american embassy in
jerusalem
and you know that presidents have been
talking about that for decades every
president said they were going to do
that they never had the guts to do it
i also recognized israeli sovereignty
over the golan heights
and that's been 52 years they've been
talking about that i got it done in
about two hours
and instead of endless war we're forging
peace in the middle east
so i get nominated for three nobel peace
prizes
different subjects
and i told the story the other night i
was in florida where
pennsylvania i told our first lady
darling we're gonna have the greatest
publicity i've ever had tonight
crops props how's this happening how
they doing in florida how the
three four stories one after
another where's my nobel peace prize i
don't talk about
i said you know darling this news is a
little tough it's a little tough to
crack
when obama got his nobel prize it was so
early
he didn't even do anything he still
doesn't know what he got it for they
said why did you get it he said i have
no idea
there's that guy
they went on a hunting trip my son don
he loves hunting and he went
kevin don and about 300 of the governors
your previous terry
uh your previous governor's friends and
they all went hunting and it was like
25 degrees below zero the only two guys
that stood out there the whole time
were kevin and donald trump jr and they
came back
everyone else was back in about 15
minutes terry right they're all back and
they wanted to go back into the lodge
the hell with
us and after a weekend my son comes back
and kevin comes back
and you two guys didn't even know what
they were talking about you didn't know
what the problem was right
people don't know that about don and
they don't know that about but kevin is
fantastic thank you kevin for being here
appreciate it he's a real he's a real
guy
so i'm ending the old wars and biden
will lead us into new wars
and we did more in 47 months than biden
did in 47 years and that's a fact
and if you look at the democrats they're
pushing the most far-left agenda
ever put forward by a presidential
nominee
their plan would destroy your social
security
destroy protections for pre-existing
conditions
biden vowed to terminate our travel bans
and jihadist regions you know i got the
travel ban
everyone said no that's not nice i said
really it's not nice to come up and blow
up cities either is it
we won in the united states supreme
court and he wants to end it
and search refugee admissions by 700
meaning 700 opening the floodgates to
radical
islamic terrorism no thank you no thank
you sleepy joe he'll ban
school choice and he'll ban charter
schools very important places and
it all starts you know civil rights all
starts with the education
and uh we need school choice in the
second term i will provide school choice
to every parent in america
we've already started glory sorry
you know it's an incredible thing
because it's great education for less
money it's sort of a crazy thing less
money
great educations and just to sort of
finish up a vote
for republicans is a vote for safe
communities
great jobs and a limitless future for
all americans
over the next four years we will make
america
into the manufacturing superpower of the
world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all it's already happened
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms your
second amendment
we will strike down terrorists to
threaten our citizens
and we will keep america out of
ridiculous
horrible endless foreign wars
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
we have never ever been even close to as
strong
as we are right now greatest equipment
ever
in our history and we will ensure
peace through strength
and if you remember when i ran they said
oh he's a very militant kind of a guy
we'll be in a war the first week well
where's the war
where's the war and i'm making other
countries pay because you know
nato they weren't paying their bills
they were delinquent to use a new york
real estate term
they weren't paying their bills i said
you got to pay the secretary general of
nato is my single biggest fan
they're paying 130 billion dollars a
year more now because they said look
you got to pay you got to pay they rip
us on trade and then we're supposed to
protect them
the european union so nato so they're
paying 130
million more going to 410 billion
dollars more
each year so that's it
where are the wars he's going to get us
into a war where are the wars
they don't want any part of us nobody
wants any part of us in the world that
we're tired of being ripped off as a
country
we will end surprise medical building
we will you know the surprise medical
billing is a disaster
it's ending as of january 1st require
price transparency all signed all done
january 1st can you imagine if i lose
and i've done all these things they kick
in on january 1st
you're going to say boy that biden's
done a great job on price transparency
and they'll say what do you think and he
has no idea what the hell it is
and further reduce the cost of
prescription drugs we went to a favored
nation's clause
so that we will pay the lowest drug
prices in the world
okay we will strongly protect medicare
and social security
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
america will land the first woman on the
moon in the united states
will be the first nation to land an
astronaut on mars
[Applause]
and you know when i took over nasa was
basically closed it was shredded it was
nothing
and now it's the number one preeminent
space center
anywhere in the world by far we will
stop
the radical indoctrination of our
students and restore patriotic education
to our schools
we will teach our children to love our
country
honor our history and always respect our
great american flag
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national model
in god we trust and it won't change
[Applause]
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people of
iowa
[Applause]
so get your friends get your family
get your neighbors get your workers and
co-workers
and get the hell out to vote because if
i don't get iowa i won't believe that
one
i may never have to come back here again
if i don't get iowa i'll never be
back you understand that kim i will say
this there has never been a president
has done more for farmers and ranchers
for the farm belt for iowa there's never
been a president
that's even come close to what i've done
and i will say that and i'll say it loud
and clear
i'll say that loud and clear
from cambridge to council bluffs from
cedar rapids to
rock rapids from davenport to right here
in des moines
we stand on the shoulders of iowa
patriots who gave their blood
sweat and tears for this beloved nation
we inherit the legacy of american heroes
nobody has anything more than what you
have
so much look at yourselves and look
where you've come
look even in the world of politics iowa
it's iowa
and by the way as long as i'm here
iowa and i made this pledge to you four
years ago
iowa will always come first in the
rotation you know what that means right
there's a lot of pressure let's put them
back i said no you're not putting them
back
you know why because that's called the
opposite of cancel culture that's called
a great american tradition iowa
will always be number one okay you can
forget it
we inherit the legacy of american heroes
who cross the oceans
blazed the trails settled the continent
came the wilderness laid down the
railroads
dug out the panama canal raised up the
skyscrapers
won two world wars defeated fascism and
communism and landed our brave american
astronauts
on the face of the moon so much you've
done
we made america into the single greatest
nation in the history of the world
and the best is yet to come
[Applause]
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country we are returning power to you
the american people
with your help your devotion and your
drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning
winning
[Applause]
because we are one movement we are one
people in one family
we are one glorious nation
under god and together with the
incredible people of iowa
we have made america wealthy again
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
we will make america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you iowa thank you
thank you very much
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
cause you're in a new town there's
[Music]
and i'm sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you listening
[Music]
but you've got to know this
[Music]
to the ymca i'm sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you can hang out with all the boys
[Music]
i felt numbness
oh
[Music]
[Music]
they have everything
is
[Music]
pick yourself off the ground
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
you wanna be
[Music]
[Music]
just a small town
[Music]
he took the midnight drink is
[Music]
[Music]
it goes on and on and on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
shadows
[Music]
[Music]
somewhere
[Music]
working hard to get my feel
everybody wants a friend
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
goes on and on and on
[Music]
in
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Music]
be
don't stop believing
still
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
me
[Music]
is
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
a little drink
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
yes
[Music]
saturday
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she packed my bags last night pre-flight
zero out nine a.m
and i'm gonna be high
[Music]
as a kite by then
[Music]
i miss the earth so much i miss my wife
it's lonely out of space
[Music]
on such a time
that's quite
[Music]
and i think it's gonna be a long long
time brings me round and get
[Music]
oh
[Music]
and i think it's gonna be a long long
time bring
me around and get
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
to raise your kids
in fact it's cold as hell
[Music]
and there's no one there to raise them
[Music]
i don't understand
it's just my job five days a week